hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
this is the maths trick that's blowing
up the internet right now
ben stevens tweeted out this fun trick
x percent of y is equal to y percent of
x
how does it work
he also provided an example
let's say you want to do 4 of 75 that's
not that easy to do
what you imagine in your head is
flipping the two numbers so you instead
calculate seventy-five percent of four
that's much easier because that's equal
to three
therefore four percent of 75 is also
equal to 3.
why does this trick work
we start out with x percent of y
which is mathematically represented as x
over 100 that's x percent and of y means
multiplied by y
since we're multiplying x and y they
commute so we have y over 100 multiplied
by x and now y over 100 is y percent
and we're going to take that of x so
we've shown that x percent of y is equal
to y percent of x
here's another example of using the
trick let's say you wanted to calculate
16 of 25
what you instead do in your head is flip
the two numbers and you take twenty-five
percent of sixteen
which is easier to do and that's equal
to four
therefore sixteen percent of twenty-five
is also equal to four
now this trick can also be useful in
more complicated calculations let's say
you needed to do twenty five percent of
a hundred and ten plus eleven percent of
two hundred and fifty
at first it doesn't look like this trick
will be very useful but what you can do
is you can factor 250 into 25 and 10.
we're now going to flip the 25 and the
11 percent
so we again flip these two numbers so we
have 25 percent of 11 times ten
now eleven times ten is equal to a
hundred and ten so we now have
twenty-five percent of a hundred and ten
plus twenty-five percent of a hundred
and ten
this will be equal to fifty percent of
one hundred and ten which is much easier
to do and that's equal to 55
so we've solved a rather complicated
problem with this neat little trick
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on youtube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world they have over 100
million views and the channel has over 1
million subscribers please subscribe for
free to get the newest videos and email
me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
you can check out my merchandise on
teespring you can check out my books
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon thanks for
watching and thanks for your support